c'est indéniable hiver nous sommes plus
apte à prendre quelques kilos même
lorsque l'on essaie de faire attention
en moyenne chacun prend entre 0,5 et 2
kilos durant cette période
ce phénomène s'explique par une
succession de raison d'en arrêter repas
de fête entre noël et le jour de l'an
mais aussi des événements calendaires
comme la galette des rois à la
chandeleur ou pâques
sans compter que l'hiver est aussi
propice à des plats plus riches pour se
réchauffer comme l'art athlètes la
tartiflette à les attaques peu d'appétit
à tous des plats très gras qui ne font
pas de cadeaux côté prise de poids
d'autres raisons s'ajoutent à ces
phénomènes de débordements alimentaire
mais alors pourquoi est-ce que l'on
prend plus de poids en hiver le docteur
original da luz est avec nous ce soir
pour tout nous expliquer mais aussi pour
nous donner ses conseils gélane allouche
médecin généraliste à paris merci
docteur alors vous avez un livre en plus
qu'on va montrer voilà exactement la
méthode et pato détox cependant ça veut
dire qu'il faut manger des pâtes et
l'enclume et c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
exactement alors qu'ils qui fait
attention déjà à son poids est ce que
vous faites attention chez vous qui
passez tension et bernard montiel depuis
des années à moi depuis toujours mais de
mais c'est normal chez moi c'est à dire
que je sais en plus on ne répond pas les
que de vous demander si vous allez dire
quoi après il s'appelle figurez vous que
le soleil brille le tester vous
critiquez un fait que j'aime le soleil
le soleil un facteur très important ça
fait maigrir non merci beaucoup du poids
en hiver il ya trois raisons de la prise
de points divers docteur la profession
la première elle est évidente c'est que
on sent moins bouge - assassinant le
froid ouais on chez soi ouais y'a une
deuxième raison qui est très importante
c'est le manque de soleil
parce qu'en fait le soleil d'ailleurs
même où le rejoint voilà et en fait elle
s'est liée à la présence et à la
quantité de vitamine d voilà c'est ça
voilà la vitamine b6 une vitamine
absolument incroyable d'ailleurs quand
on dit vitamine d ont dit les vitamines
et pascal à plusieurs et quand on prend
la vitamine d on prend en général les
deux la d2 la d3 et qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait cette vitamine d d'abord elle joue
un rôle on est on le connaît sur l'os
nous pourrons si fier il faut de la
vitamine d'une calcium et de la vitamine
d si vous prenez du calcium tout seul ça
marche pas
on n'a pas de cela et puis et puis pour
aussi fier aux faire du sport et
d'exercices d'accord ce canton tire sur
les os ça les oblige à ce site certains
d'accord il faut sauver le deuxième rôle
c'est l'immunité et on le sait
aujourd'hui avec le co vite c'est que ça
tous les gens qui ont une immunité quand
une vitamine d basse ont plus de risques
de faire des formes sévères de d'accord
qu'il faut avoir un bon niveau de
vitamine d est globalement les français
sont assez carencés en vitamine
tenteront dégoûte le matin on peut
prendre soin en goûte le matin soit en
une dose unique tous les deux mois moi
je recommande plus tôt soit une ampoule
tck les semaines soit des gouttes le
matin alors il faut prendre du poids en
hiver parce que déjà cas on pas de
sonner après c'est vraiment parce qu'on
bouge on bouge beaucoup moins il n'ya
pas de salut et puis nous sommes les
enfants des survivants on vivait dans
des cavernes et on chassait l'été et on
stockait l'hiver qu'il faut être capable
de stocker diverses pour garder parce
qu'on sait pas quand on va manger
donc on a une physiologie qui est liée à
la lumière et au soleil dans savoir
aussi que le soleil en hiver est
beaucoup plus bas donc les rayons et les
fréquences les longueurs d'onde sont
très différents et qu'en fait on a plus
tendance à stocker parce que l'été le
soleil est haut les uv sont plus
puissants et à ce moment là les cellules
600 gr merde voilà le stock - comme les
écureuils
ça c'est le deuxième il s'arrête pas là
parce que nous on ne s'arrête pas là ça
s'arrête pas là non bien sûr il ya une
hormone s'appelle la leptine qui l
hormone de la satiété
la leptine c'est une hormone qui en
force à titouan temps sia lisez avec la
vitamine d sont plus on a de la ville à
mille des pleurs et du soleil
bon d'accord alors et puis je trouve un
bien avec le confinement plus est
lorsqu'on bouge plus c'est ça le
confinement ces personnes sont regardés
netflix et système et on bouge on parle
beaucoup des problèmes des restaurateurs
et à juste titre mais dans les cinq ou
six ans et une canada oui il ya
l'alimentation aussi à les plats d'hiver
voilà vous savez ils pourraient être
tentés de manger de la raclette
oui mais vous ne mangez pas tous les
soirs non alors justement et moi quand
je mange de la raclette juste mange pas
de charcuterie mange pas de pommes de
terre je fais raquette brocoli
vous pouvez actionner les trois conseils
pour éviter la prise de poids en hiver
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
regardent et un des prix les plus jeunes
qui ont pris du poids et benjamin
castaldi par le fait comme j'ai mis mes
docteurs
quels sont les droits dont c'est la
règle c'est de considérer que l'exercice
physique c'est qu'il pleuve qu'il vente
ou qu'il sait ça en été ou en hiver
donc il faut sortir 5 faut bouger mais
on peut pas ainsi mais chez nous qu est
ce qu on peut faire ici aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la marque cherche ovale à
bord d'abord alors marcher ça suffit
parce que si on veut perdre un peu de
poids il faut mouiller la chemise à
jabot mouille pas la chemise en lin
monsieur zarabi on a des soucis si vous
êtes entraînés vous pouvez le faire en
cardio classique d'accord soit si vous
n'êtes pas entraîner vous commencé
doucement il faut pas se faire mal car
ce qui est important c'est de faire
longtemps et pas uniquement grâce à des
fractionnés d'accord exemple vous fait
vous allez courir tranquillement bien
couvert avec un podcast un placard est
d'une émission par exemple et puis vous
courrez pendant cinq minutes cool et
puis pendant 30 secondes bamba vous
aller à fond d'accord mais à ce moment
là c'est que c'est magique le le muscle
va commencer à sécréter des petits
traits particuliers qui vont libérer les
graisses qui sont dans les années mais
aussi ces tentatives des priorités
vous pouvez aussi donc faire du
fractionné faire du continue
malheureusement les piscines sont
fermées mais la piscine skate mieux
assez calmement faucheurs de tresses
régnante à une chez lui donc
la star ac ou non en suisse et en
musculation
parce qu'il ya une nation la musique a
vu de musculation à l'arrivée
franchement je n'ai pas eu le temps de
vérifier mais on a montré que utiliser
les biceps et les triceps avait une
influence sur les sécrétions du pancréas
alors ça je vais vérifier parce que
c'est un centre de recherches de
strasbourg c'est vouloir savoir faut
faire de la musculation donc faire voilà
la musculation et surtout du buste c'est
extrêmement important
et puis il ya une autre une autre chose
c'est que il faut essayer de faire des
séances de respiration un peu de
respiration abdominale parce que ça
permet de masser son choix ce que le
grand patron de la régulation c'est du
sucre dans l'organisme
c'est le foie et le foie d'accord il
faut pas que le foie gras d'accord et
pas qu'ils soient gras manger des sucres
index glycémique plutôt bas qu'est ce
que je fais c'est ça qui regarde
toujours si le sucre et un index
glycémique bas et est donc là alors donc
les conseils donc ces spasmes et alors
qu'il ya plein de gens qui vont venir
wim on le sait ça y'a pas mais pourquoi
ils ne le font pas ben non mais c'est
vrai parce qu'il a peur de venir parce
qu'on le sait sur le cac ce n'est vrai
quoi oui est ce que c'est bien le jeune
séquentiel c'est l'accession à la
question alors on va rappeler ce que
c'est que je check ans et ça c'est
important pour la savoie c1 c'est une
méthode qui fait que vous ne vous allez
sauter en gros un ou deux repas dépend
du type de se dire on vous mangez plus à
partir de 18h et devront manger dans
leur âme à 13 heures voilà exacte et ça
alors ça aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
scientifique il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont pour beaucoup de gens qui sont
contre moi la seule la seul conseil que
je donne c'est qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
maintenir sur le long terme
moi je suis un farouche partisan de la
routine savon à des horloges avez peur
vous avez peur qu'en fait ce truc là où
ils tiennent à 1 à 2 semaines et après
on craque c'est ça et puis on en a on a
un rôle social qu'est ce qu'on va faire
quand les restaurants vont rouvrir et
qu'on vous invite à déjeuner vous dites
non chez un jeune sans moi je suis
jamais déjeuné chose je sais pas mais en
plus c'est très peu d'amis aller au
restaurant mais non mais non mais non
mais non ma part ça c'est vrai que on se
dit ça ya plein de gens qui font ça re
et ça marche bien mine de rien ça marche
bien ça marche bien
il ya quand même le fait que vous savez
ce qu'on dit aussi c'est que ce qui est
mangé le matin et brûlé ce qui est
manger le soir et stocker d'accord nous
parce qu'on on va s'coucher avait par
ailleurs il vaut mieux manger le matin
que le soir
l'estomac une mémoire par exemple si ou
sauternes
les mémoires non c'est nous sortait un
ou deux repas il paraît que l'estomac se
rattrape après et rostock ce que vous
lui offrez nous ne porterons pas c'est
pas l'estomac qui stocke c'est vrai
c'est pas vrai c'est pas mal quand même
pas mal quand l'arrivée attendue 20h31
pourquoi il faut savoir qu'on a dans
notre cerveau dans la zone la plus
archaïque
on a un petit noyau qui compte les
calories quelle qu'elle soit rapide plus
site protein coillard déjà comme ça il
ya un noyau il ya un noyau 4 neurones
comme une batteur de routes coupées en
amont qui compte avec on dira alors tu
as pris trois boulettes comme celui-là
des habitudes parce que lui il est
chargé de votre poids qu'on appelle au
must asics à dire le poison ivy le poids
de survie pas sûr et donc comme on dit
dans les cas des hostas pluie il faisait
tout pour vous pousser à aller chercher
l'alimentation et donc quand vous
arrêtez de manger lui va se mettre en
mode recherche et donc au repas suivant
il veut récupérer les canaris lui il
faut entre neuf mois et un an pour
considérer que le nouveau point est un
poids vivant vivable voilà c'est ça le
problème c'est l'échec de tous les
régimes qui va dire ça oui quel que soit
le régime que vous faites là se fiche du
match aller le confinement ça m'a
beaucoup de gens qui ont pris du poids
par wifi demande il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont pris du poids de confinement
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont compensé
parce que psychologique moi ça n'a rien
de pire que le confiner rocheuses
expliquer pourquoi je vous dis la vérité
j'avais arrêté les granola et bamako
sinon j'ai repris voilà cette importante
c'est que ce qu'on a compris avec cette
crise c'est que le seul vrai capital que
nous ayons c'est notre santé c'est vrai
c'est le seul et celui-là on peut pas
l'acheter on peut pas le racheter donc
moi je me bats pour que la prévention
parce qu'il ya des tas de maladies comme
le diabète de type 2 comme les maladies
cardiovasculaires on pourrait prévenir
on a du temps tous les organes vous
prévienne mais vous tu vas voir si tu
continues comme ça tu vas avoir et on
fait rien c'est la prévention est 40
fois moins cher que les amène à vern
pour ça pour savoir pont d'abord il faut
tous les faire un veille check up
ouais d'accord et puis il faut regarder
il faut pas se dire tiens j'ai un peu
avec la glycémie à jeun c'est très
important
c'est le taux de sucre dans le sang
voilà agen c'est normalement entre 0,75
et 1 g 05 par litre et puis le diabète
c'est quand on a au dessus de 1,26
accord à deux reprises entre les deux il
ya une zone grise s'appelle le
prédiabète entre 1,06 et 1,26
la plupart du temps on se dit bon j'ai
un gramme disent c'est pas grave je vais
faire un peu attention on fait jamais
attention
et puis au bout de 5 ans 6 ans 7 ans
damas le diabète arrive et autant le
prédiabète et réversible autant le dire
avec lui il est irréversiblement et donc
après c'est une autre paire de manches
alors il ya des médicaments bien sûr et
bien plein de choses mais après ça il
faut sa vie après c'est se dire c'est
assez de cette phrase du dalaï lama que
j'aime beaucoup il dit tu cherches là
bas je suis malade malade non non pas du
tout riddick
les hommes passent la moitié de leur vie
a gagné l'argent en négligeant leur
santé et passe la deuxième partie de
leur vie à dépenser de l'argent pour
regagner leur c'est vrai je pense que
vraiment à l'application sont sa
[Rires]
naissance on ne parle jamais mais jamais
et pourtant tous les médecins me disent
que c'est prépondérant pour maigrir cmh
et beaucoup beaucoup mais je sais moi
c'est pour ça que voilà non mais non
mais là où vous avez absolument raison
ah c'est que quand vous mâcher vous avez
sur la longue vous avez à peu près dix
douze mille capteurs sucré salé amer
délicieux et ils sont reliés à une
glande qui est fondamental parce qu'elle
elle règne sur votre vie ça s'appelle
c'est un nom affreux c'est quoi
s'appelle le noyau accumbens bien sûr
affreux il s'appelle le rewind système
de récompense marque quand vous avez le
sucre sur le bout de la langue
à ce moment là ça va dans le noyau
commun et il fait de la dopamine de
plaisir et le cerveau il dit ah c'est
très bien comme ça
ah ouais quand vous ne marchez pas non
vous ne marchez pas que vous avalez ils
n'ont pas le temps de déclencher le
noyau à dakarois donc l'arrêt et à ce
moment là on avale et on gobe et si vous
gobez à ce moment là vous n'avez pas à
l'école ici mais moi ça me rend heureuse
de manger on n'a plus rien en ce moment
ben je peux vous dire que vraiment plat
il arrive le soir
ben c'est mon bonheur et va me donner du
temps manger au nez du vin mais c'est
surtout quand on n'a pas de mec je peux
dire
à la cour des comptes on mangeait des
radios